I personally really value traditional  gender roles I think the most beautiful  thing a woman can do is be a wife and  raise children and nurture them and I  love a man to be strong I want him to  protect and provide because that allows  me as a woman to get into my feminine  energy which I believe is where women  are most happiest when women feel safe  we feel protected be feminine and be  happy and be sweet and for some reason  those at the top the Elise whatever you  want to call them are trying to switch  this all around and what happens is men  and women start to reject each other we  don't like each other I don't want a  weak man and a man doesn't want a  masculine woman and so we don't get  together and then there's no children it  leaves Society down a very dangerous and  dark and also a very lonely path